you know there are many traditions in
the movie business they'd always be nice
to people on the way up you know in case
your career should suddenly begin to
lose altitude stay humble always answer
your phone no matter who else is in the
car one of the better traditions the
happier traditions always bring back
last year's Best Actor to present this
year's Best Actress and here to perform
that semi sacred right is mr. Robert du
bad
our five nominated actresses have a good
deal in common with on screen women they
play each has a strength and a
discipline which she brought to her
character roles which also serve as role
models and tonight we honor five of the
best for Best Performance by an actress
in a leading role the nominees are for
her portrayal as the young English woman
transformed by events during the days of
the empire Judy Davis and A Passage to
India
as a widow and mother returns to farming
the land for a new beginning Sally Field
in places in the heart
as a determined woman who refuses to
give in to the pressures of government
bureaucracy Jessica Lange in country
for her role as a champion of women's
rights and liberties in
nineteenth-century America Vanessa
Redgrave and the Bostonians
as the faithful and courageous wife who
fights hard times and temptation [ __ ]
Spacek in the river
and the winner is Sally Field in places
Oh bettan what you did for me you
changed my life truly this means so much
more to me this time I don't know why I
think the first time I hardly felt it
because it was all so new I owe a lot to
the cast to my players to Lindsey and
John and Danny and Ed and Amy my little
friends Ginny and Yankton I will out to
my family for holding me together and
loving me and having patience with his
obsession of me but I want to say thank
you to you I haven't had an orthodox
career and I've wanted more than
anything to have your respect the first
time I didn't feel it but this time I
feel it and I can't deny the fact that
you like me right now
you